tuberculosis is communicated from one
person to another almost always through
the air this film will show how airborne
infection takes place how the pattern
was verified and how such spread of
infection can be controlled until a few
years ago we did not know the actual
mode of transmission of the germ
there were several notions however
through direct contact with germs on the
bedding of tuberculosis patients on
their clothing in dust that accumulated
in their rooms are carried in moist
droplets coughed or sneezed into the air
the droplet Theory was nearest the truth
even though particles as large as
droplets dust or lint actually cannot
reach the depths of the lung necessary
for infection transmission begins of the
source usually a person with open
untreated tuberculosis to understand how
it happens one must know the particular
mechanics involved strong exploration
such as sneezing or coughing blasts
forth air from the lungs at the same
time it shears off droplets from the
secretions lining a respiratory tract
once outside the body these droplets the
larger of which we see as mist
evaporate rapidly their solid residue
called a droplet nucleus may contain one
or more tubercle bacilli these tiny
nuclei are light enough to remain
floating about until vented to the
outdoors they follow wherever the air
currents lead if this contaminated air
is enclosed in a hospital room or a home
it carries the threat of infection to
all susceptible people within the area
at some moment in this exposure the
susceptible person inhales an infectious
particle drawing it into his lungs
usually it must reach the alveoli to
take effect to do so the particle must
pass all the notch
traps in a respiratory tract the size
required to accomplish this feat is
estimated to be no more than five
microns in diameter dropped at nuclei
range from one to five microns in
diameter using the vehicle of dropped of
nuclei very limp tubercle bacilli
reached the alveoli where they are
implanted on susceptible tissue and
later initiate infection to demonstrate
this pattern of transmission and
infection a four year study of
tuberculous infection beginning in 1956
was made under the direction of dr.
Richard L Reilly at the VA hospital in
Baltimore Professor William F Wells who
originated the dropped of nucleus theory
in 1934 and conceived of tuberculosis
study in Baltimore was a member of the
study group the study was carried out in
a six room pilot ward with a penthouse
overhead an independent air conditioning
system moved air through the patient's
rooms then exhausted it through animal
exposure chambers in the penthouse the
study sought to answer two questions
first whether animals if placed at a
reasonable distance can be infected by
breathing air contaminated with droplet
nuclei produced by patients with open TB
and second if so whether such airborne
infection can be eliminated by
disinfecting the air when an average of
one hundred and fifty six animals were
exposed continuously toward air during
the first two years of the study
71 infections resulted out of an average
of 120 exposed continuously during the
second two years 63 infections resulted
this test leaves no doubt that
infectious droplets nuclei were present
in the air of the tuberculosis ward the
tests also demonstrated that there is a
wide range of infectious potential among
patients in a case involving laryngeal
tuberculosis one patient infected 14
animals in three days a rate of
contagion estimated to be greater than
that of measles although some cases did
not infect any animals those patients
showing a high infectious potential
invariably open untreated cases the
study showed that the ward air harbored
approximately 1 unit of contagion per
12,500 cubic feet of air this is roughly
the amount of air a hospital ward worker
will breathe during duty hours in six
months to a year although this is a
remarkably low concentration of
infective units it is in keeping with
previous observations that household
contacts of people with active TB often
require prolonged exposure before
acquiring infection it seems probable
that the drop of nucleus mechanism is of
predominant importance in the spread of
tuberculosis in the community if
tuberculosis is transmitted largely
through the air we face the question how
can infection be blocked the pilot study
data indicate that three different
methods may provide defense the first
and simplest is by mere ventilation
sufficient to dilute the amount of
contamination in the air this means
leaving doors and windows open for free
ventilation insofar as possible
the second is disinfection of the air in
a controlled unit of the study air from
the pilot Ward was irradiated with
ultraviolet light before passing into
the control chamber no animal in this
study developed infection the finding
indicates that disinfection is effective
when practicable the third method is
through effective drug treatment in the
study it was found that a patient's
capacity to infect is virtually blocked
within days or a few weeks after
receiving effective drug treatment this
loss of infectious potential becomes
apparent before smears and culture turn
negative in curbing infection quick and
effective treatment is an important tool